hey guys this is andrew for
trainsenses.com i've been working as a
professional trainer for the past six
years in hong kong
and i'm right now doing some youtube
videos where i explain
the way i do my analysis so it's
technical but it's fundamental as well
where i found my information and how you
guys can do it as well
so if you want to know all about all the
stuff you are in the right place
so today i want to talk about amc guys
which is a very controversial topic
i had a lot of comments and you know
good and bad comments on my
latest video i did on the stock so i
want to do one more
to update you guys on what happened and
what i see coming
let's get into it
[Music]
all right so first maybe we can start
with looking at the chart quickly
so the earnings no no update on the
earnings but we know they had some
better earnings you know in the first
quarter
of 2021 i mean they're probably gonna be
better
in terms of volume guys uh i like to
check the volume so we had one billion
shares trading at
uh five so it's like around five billion
usd
training all right the max volume so
it's around 250
of the total market cap the short
interest guys so once again uh to find
the short interest it's very interesting
because i had a lot of people telling me
you are wrong on the short interest you
don't know what you're talking about but
guys i'm a professional
trader so i have bloomberg which i don't
use for
my videos because i'm not allowed but i
cross check my data and i can
find my data on market beat guys this is
free
you can go there and i can tell you that
it's not exactly the same
on bloomberg you have 10 here you have
23 and this
is data from january 29th so if you want
to know what are the
short interest right now you need to
work on the repo
market and you need to ask for some live
information which is very expensive so
nobody actually gets it
so i don't have it but what i know is
that you know the short interest is not
very big it was 70 before it dropped
heavily guys so basically all the short
guys they
uh cut the position here in this rally
all right
so this what created this short squeeze
guys and short squeeze only happen
when you have big shoot interest so what
i'm saying is that the short quiz won't
happen here again
because you don't have enough short
positions in this market
so we had around 700 in a matter of
few weeks so what is the situation now
let's go first at the on the news first
you guys know that what happened so it
was on reddit it was in wall street beds
you had this guys
this guy all right so roaring kitty so
this guy
is actually uh going to the congress
guys it all started with gme
right that rocked the market last month
played out mostly in the dark
on any news internet forums we're
talking here about reddit bootstrap bets
uh even twitter which is not a dark
forum or whatever and off extension
platform
so blah blah blah this drama will come
out in the open
and it will be the government's first
public attempt to sort out what happened
in the last two weeks of january because
guys what we don't know
what i don't know what nobody knows is
are
these guys insiders do they have
information that they shared
illegally to actually benefit from it
which is called
front running or market manipulation and
they're going to have some issues if
it's the case
so let's d let's see if they are just
you know some kind of
very good day trader that just had the
feeling or if they had some information
that you know they can't lie to the
congress they will find out if they did
so this is going to be very interesting
to look at
then about amc guys this is something i
want to show i would know you guys
are going to put dislikes because you
did on my last video when i'm
not saying good things about amc but you
need to face the reality guys you you
want you need to
look at the truth all right this is what
happened in the amc rally
so this are some people that own uh
amc you know in their portfolio so an
investment management firm
a return so blah blah blah miller value
partners
was a detractor for the portfolio so
they say amc was a
detractor for the portfolio in the
fourth quarter of 2020 because it
lost a lot of money for the past three
months nc delivered an impressive 88
percent return all right guys
so there was a real gross and return to
550 then the interesting thing to notice
guys is what happened during this rally
so uh amc entertainment so these guys
that basically you know cinema and stuff
like this of course it's not working
during the kovid
and i'm not sure it's going to come back
very soon to see how the vaccine is
going to work especially like you know
with all the different kind of like
uh covey that arrive is it still going
to be effective we don't know but
you know it's not good to do cinema in
this kind of situation
so i plan on discussing here why it was
worth at least 10
per share all right so this is what the
guys that own it that know everything
about the firm
was saying and then they say that
basically when the stock
went high you know with all the
speculative uh powers that were coming
in the game
we sold it around 14 during the last
week of jan
this was a modest profit for most
clients but the last for some others
so they basically were lucky they are
saying
uh those of good luck which are hardly
accept from the universe as it seemed
somewhat lacking in the portfolio of
late all right
so basically the professionals what did
they do when amc
was uh here flying at this levels all
right 14
so it was here they sold it to whom to
uh
the retail guys so this is usually the
stuff that is happening
on the markets all right when something
is very overvalued
people who know what it's worth are
selling it and people who don't know are
buying it all right i'm not saying there
were no chance it would it would go
higher just like jimmy did
i'm just saying that these guys they are
you know
they they were the selling pressure so
it's not short
it was natural sellers guys all right so
people say we hold we don't sell all
right but those who hold even more
uh and who are actually you know uh
intervening with the firm
politics are actually those who are
selling here
so now what is the situation i think so
we are
back to something more normal all right
so all these guys on the street bets
that are gonna see the congress so if
they had some you know uh inside
information
uh they will have issues so for now they
are not talking about amc anymore
but we have a nice support at five guys
all right so this stock
used to be around 30 even more 50
stuff like this so now just technically
yes
uh we are we have the the moving
averages coming just here at 4 30 so
wait a bit
maybe in a few weeks they're gonna be at
five and we're gonna have a nice
double support so here it was the
initial i just put my support level at
the maximum level just before the gap up
guys and here it was uh
you know you can see it worked it played
it acted as a
resistance as well uh here as well here
it was support all right so this
five level is a strong support now so
guys it's maybe
the time to reload some of amc shares uh
and you know just hold it for a long
period of time and not expecting
anything crazy
all right just play it the normal way
look at the volumes the volumes are back
to you know very it was 1 billion
now it's trading you know 100 million so
10 times less so guys
this is uh you know back to something
more normal and
yes i'm not uh bearish on this i mean
like in the long term
it's probably a very nice level to value
so if you guys along the stuff
just hold it all right hold it as you as
you like to say
so yeah that's it for me i hope you guys
enjoyed this video
and once again i hope i managed to make
myself clear about the short interest
about how the professionals are actually
uh handling this kind of situation
and about the story that are behind amc
and if you did please don't forget to
click the like subscribe
so you're gonna be the first to know
when i upload anything new and i'm going
to talk about all this
stuff guys so stay close to show